how much of success in life do you think
is uh engineered and how much is
Mystical I and how much does it differ
from person to person because I for me
personally maybe I enjoy it maybe I'm
genetically built that way but I exist
more in the mystical so I don't make
plans I travel last summer in Ukraine
with no plan I just went there no plan
I didn't know how I'm going to meet the
president of the country I didn't know
anybody and so
there's no plan there's no clear thing
you're just roaming around and that's
how I've existed in life and it there's
something about giving yourself over to
the flow of nature that I just enjoy it
makes life so much fun
it's
awesome when you can do it did you
engineer though I'm going to put myself
in the place when you got on the plane
to go to the destination that was an
engineered choice
of
and maybe I'll meet and I'll run into
and I can
work up a sit down with
so the engineering Choice was putting
your shoes on preferably get you know I
always say this the hardest part about
going to gyms putting your shoes on
right so to getting on the plane that
was an engineered thought with the goal
in mind but I don't know how I'm going
to do it
the choice yeah putting the shoes on
yeah
but there's not a clear it's a fog what
happens after the shoe is gone
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's gonna take that leap so I I wonder
how much uh
for people who are successful in this
world in finding what makes them uh
truly happy and fulfilled how much of it
is engineer how much it is Mystical
how much was it for you well I'll say
this like an hour at winter right
about green lights which is basically
the last 40 years of my life I thought
that 85 90 of my successes were going to
be
obviously engineered
or I could see the signs it's all the
habits here's what I did yep that add up
got the solution got the conclusion
I was
very surprised when I noticed it was
probably less than 50 percent
and that most of the real successes of
my for when I
trusted
the one I trusted
that I didn't have to Define it that I
only trusted that I didn't have to go
what's the measurement
what's the score
what this leads to what what's next
um
and I for me
that that's still there's still a
challenge for me
daily
now is to trust and not be because I can
be I could I think I can be overly
practical
and I think I can over over compensate
and miss out on Magic
because I'm still
going
wait but do you are we given enough am I
are we giving enough the measure and
credit to actuality
are we or am I giving enough credit to
this is this these are the steps to take
and this is reality
I I think
I'm reminded
when I when I trust because that going
with the Mystic just to put yourself on
the plane was the engineer be getting
there and as you say you've seen you say
you roll in that mystical it takes a lot
of trust yeah
trust in the inevitable Amen on that to
but not knowing where it actually ends
you it's it's a feeling more than um
uh I don't think it's a Clear Vision
right
it's kind of like a feeling that guides
you towards uh
towards a place with with uh
without a clear name without clear
characteristics it just kind of pulls
you there
where do you get that courage and Trust
to go with your gut your your feeling
and is there
for instance three days later you sit
down is there if you did if that if that
doesn't happen
is there a sense
a week two weeks later now when you come
back
To America that like ah
I've failed
foreign
looking back to try to analyze what went
right we went wrong that kind of thing
uh yeah that that engine is always there
but I think what pulls me forward in
life what makes me really grateful and
fulfilled is noticing the thing you
mentioned noticing the magic
and kind of going towards it
sort of just sitting back
um both in tragedy and then Triumph so
in war there's a lot of tragedy but
there's somehow
uh one of the things you see in in war
this is the first war I've experienced
and seen seen the front
is the loss that people lose their homes
and all this kind of stuff
the thing that rises from that is the
love for each other
so they uh the people I've spoken with
don't give a damn about the home don't
give a damn about that on farms and the
animals they lost don't don't give a
damn about
um having to move and all this kind of
stuff as long as the family is still
there as long as the people they love
are still there and it's like
that's there's this Melancholy smile
they have on their face
like yeah this world is full of
it's full of tragedy
but life is awesome and that and
you just notice that in in little ways
everywhere
you just sit back and yeah notice the
magic and I I want more of that
and just kind of follow along with a
little ant yeah
keep noticing that kind of thing but uh
I don't know I I hope you know what I
what I think it is is other people
notice that you're the kind of person
that notices it uh and they're like I
want to hang out with that person he
seems all right like he seems one of the
uh one of the good ones one of the good
hands
do you have uh um
any certain
non-negotiable structure before that
freedom to go with the feeling
I think so there's a set of principles
of just uh basically Integrity of being
uh good to other people
like whatever that means for me there's
specific things like I I'm really into
loyalty
Above the Law right this is kind of like
there's a circle of friends I have and
that means everything
um
there's just a Basics deep kindness
towards others
uh empathy empathy towards people that
other
that others might label as um
even evil I have that kind of empathy I
believe all of us have the capacity to
do good and evil
and so I just kind of see everybody as
little babies that grow up in different
conditions and
so some do evil some do good
and this yeah there's there's all kinds
of other
uh principles
I love the dynamic between the different
humans and their full diversity I love
the the dynamic between the masculine
the feminine enjoy it the dance of it
yeah yeah
so you you have a constitution with
which you embark
you do too chasing yes I hope so
um
and then Freya for me I'd like to it's
inspiring to hear
someone like yourself go I go and I just
land and I just go I'm gonna feel it
um I can go back and go yeah my greatest
truth I've crossed my greatest successes
in my life are when
had trusted that and go I took a one-way
ticket
Amazon Africa
yeah and those were spiritual
and very pragmatic because they led to
dealing with with
succeeding in other in other ways that
are more pragmatic 100 and gave much
more meaning
to those things
but that's that's to be able to
go out and and say that's how you do you
have family I really want to get married
and have kids but I I'm not married and
don't have kids yet okay so actually one
of the nice things about that is you can
take bigger risks
so while I'm not married and don't have
kids I feel I owe it to myself to take
just to go go to the Amazon that
backpack on and a one-way ticket yeah
yeah because that does get harder to do
yeah
um
I missed that
sometimes
the
the whim
the song that comes on you know
yeah where's that guy from
oh they're from the place that I want to
go that I dream of I'll go there when we
take it what do I got to do I'll get a
couple shots okay go that that
there's that that was that was fun I'm
gonna do this let's get up and go you're
free yeah and go when are you back when
I
when I get there yeah it's a beautiful
beautiful thing maybe never yeah yeah my
yeah
guys you'll be coming to visit me in
this new place maybe yeah